now to do this [ __ ] here we go hello
smile for space for now temporary that's
a I'm gonna be Meg
hey what is going on YouTube now before
we go ahead and start this video yes I'm
gonna tell you guys this is a sponsored
video from this company called East Mesa
East which is a dating website but the
great thing about that is it actually
coincides with the vlog topic that I'm
gonna talk about today because it was
suggested by a lot of y'all so kind of
just you know what's together now a lot
of y'all have been asking David what do
you think about online dating it could
call now if you guys have asked me if
I've ever done online dating yes I have
now for me obviously when I tried it was
a little weird for me because when it
when I did it uh I remember a couple of
responses that I got was aren't you
dying it's tough Colin a man I'm like
[ __ ] come on calm yet down stay you try
[ __ ] the crazy thing was when she met me
in person
haha she was thoroughly disappointed now
I'm gonna tell you guys straight up my
opinion about online dating I [ __ ]
love it online dating is probably one of
the dopest things that you can do if you
want a date and you don't have a lot of
[ __ ] time now for me one of the
bigger reasons why I like online dating
is because you could cut a lot of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you put out that what
you generally like and dislike and you
get all of that [ __ ] out the way so
you guys could build on more important
topics to see if you guys can really get
along now I feel that a lot of you
people out there have like the stigma
towards dating too much what the [ __ ] is
that about
and I think one of the bigger reasons
why people have the certain stigma is
because you guys think that when you
first meet somebody you're supposed to
just automatically fall in love
when you see the person there's that
sparkle and that Korean drama moment
where you're just like oh my god who are
you your eyes sparkle and then that
dude's supposed to be like I have yet to
see an angel such as fair as you hahaha
most of the time that [ __ ] does not
happen we have a lot of expectations
about what we think we like about
somebody but here's the thing you don't
really [ __ ] know that until you
experience it for yourself I personally
used to think because my mom was such an
angry and combative woman that I would
never never want to be with a woman that
crazy [ __ ] lies I likes the crazy
[ __ ] I started dating these girls who
had traits that I thought I liked but it
turned out it really wasn't it and the
only way for me to figure that [ __ ] out
is because I dated a lot dating really
opens your eyes to figuring yourself out
more than anything else I would have
never thought that I wanted to be with
an abusive woman until I started doing
even the girl that I'm with now Muriel
she kicks my ass on a regular basis you
know I'm happy you know you do these
dating websites that kind of help you
find a match and if the person doesn't
happen to work out the first time guess
what you got a lot more options you
can't just give up nowadays you ask her
online even if she calls you fat and
ugly
it don't matter she never met you [ __ ]
my feelings don't get hurt through words
baby has to be face to face you trying
to Netflix and [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] grouse
and that's why nobody want to touch your
[ __ ] dating was just another way for me
to to meet more people talk create
stories and you know I gotta tell you
like some of my funniest and greatest
experience was because I went out there
and I did it a lot whether or not the
person fell in love with me I was
attracted to me or gave me the finger or
call me a fat [ __ ] I enjoyed every
moment of it because it got me to the
point to get me to understand who I was
as a person what I wanted in my other
person and also it got me to you know
meet Muriel and look we're happy I must
say Meryl and I met through online means
but I'm saying that a [ __ ] up a lot with
some other women just
you know I could get this one go out
there find out what you like and do the
damn thang I think I yell so much I'm
sweating through my [ __ ] right now
hey what is going on YouTube thank you
guys for supporting me and you guys are
the reason why East East East hit me up
so let me get you a lowdown on what this
is East meets each is a premier dating
site for Asian singles in North America
when you're on the site there are going
to be unique search titles such as when
you're age when you immigrate it in your
language and etc etc so why don't you
guys go ahead and check out the
description box below and there will be
a link for you to click and check it out
to meet Joe Asian persuasion thank you
guys once again for tuning in and these
sponsorships are definitely given to me
because you guys have been supporting me
so I'll hope you guys like this east
meets website let me know how it goes
and if you find an Asian honey through
it y'all let me know if it worked out
for you get out there start dating see
what you're like don't be a [ __ ] about
it do it